je souhaite à 2022 heureux j'espère
avant tout bien évidemment que la
période de pandémie qui pèse sur chaque
année depuis près de deux ans touchera à
sa fin même si nous avons conscience que
nous allons sans doute encore vivre avec
quelques temps j'espère que nous en
verrons bout très prochainement cela
dépend de chacun de nous de notre
détermination à se protéger à protéger
notre entourage
détermination attention et bien
évidemment vaccination
faisons confiance aux sachants pour
sauvegarder les soignants pour se sortir
du tunnel pour retrouver le vivre
ensemble que nous aimons tant cette
année 2022 sera celle de grands débats
avec les élections présidentielles puis
législatives
j'espère qu'il en ressortira une france
plus forte une france d'innovation une
france d'excellence une france solidaire
ou france européenne une france engagée
sur les défis climatiques
une france respectueuse de la place de
tous une france des libertés locales une
france d'espérance dans cette france
d'après qu'ovide ici au sénat sous
l'autorité du président larcher nous
prendrons diamant toute notre place
nous représentons la voix des
territoires la voie de la proximité est
bien souvent la voie de la simplicité
depuis cette salle rené monory au palais
luxembourg je suis heureux de vous
souhaiter une très bonne année
[Musique]